[inaudible]
joining me today as a writer and columnist at quill that magazine as well as a
philosophy major at Columbia University common use.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me on dude.
I had to change my shirt because your shirt looked so pressed and starched and
professional.
It's ironic because I normally dress like a complete slob.
I wear the same black hoodie every single day.
Yeah.
But I thought Ruben report you have to bring a game.
Let's do it.
I should've worn a tie,
but here we are.
Alright.
There's a lot of reasons that I want to talk to you.
Uh,
you were Sorta,
I think put on,
put on my map and put on sort of the IDW map and the map of all of the people
that care about the issues that we talk about here,
uh,
about,
what was it about five or six months ago,
something like that.
Something like that.
Your piece,
I want to get the exact title right,
was the high price of stale grievances.
And that was in [inaudible].
And you know,
I just had Claire on the show last week.
So we're going to talk about a lot of things you've been writing about.
I want to talk a little bit about what it's like to be a student at,
uh,
at a university these days,
especially on the,
that leans pretty far left and all sorts of stuff.
First,
just uh,
tell me a little bit about yourself,
where you're from,
how you grew up.
Well,
that kind of stuff
from Montclair,
New Jersey,
uh,
which is just 30 minutes outside New York City.
Nice suburb.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I had a pretty typical middle upper middle class upbringing and a great parents.
Um,
and uh,
out of,
out of high school I was going to music school actually I was dead set on being
a jazz musician and I still play drums,
Josh trombone.
Nice.
But along the line I ended up shifting paths and uh,
going into philosophy and enrolling at Columbia where I have two more years.
How do you go from jazz to philosophy?
There's probably some through line there,
right?
I don't know that there is honestly.
I think,
I think I just loved both of them and realized at a certain point that just
going to school for music was limiting.
Um,
so yeah.
Yeah.
So you said a middle class or upper middle class.
Did you have,
did your family have any particular political beliefs where you guys,
politico,
how many of that?
My,
my mother was nearly a Marxist.
She,
um,
she,
I remember her talking to me about Marx and Durkheim when I was three and four
years old.
She,
she came from the South Bronx,
immigrant,
Puerto Rican family,
very,
very poor in the 70s when the South Bronx was the picture of crime and uh,
just decay.
And she,
she was very smart woman,
ended up getting a,
trying to get an anthropology degree,
but she passed away of cancer while,
while she was getting it.
But no,
she,
I was,
I was exposed to two Marx and Durkheim and uh,
some other,
other Marxists thinkers when I was,
I could've told you their names.
When was five years old.
Wow.
My Dad is a bit of a libertarian,
but I got less of his,
his,
he was working much at the time.
So yeah.
So that,
that's a real mixed,
yeah.
Household of the politics though,
did you sort of lean one way or the other?
Yeah,
I always leaned heavily left if I,
if I leaned anywhere at all.
Yeah.
I mean as early,
Eh,
my,
the beginning of my political identity was definitely anchored around identity
politics and especially black identity politics.
Uh,
you know,
I was 24,
it was at 2013,
2014 when black lives matter started cropping up.
I was at that point very much enthusiastic about that movement.
I was posting on Facebook,
having seen a police shooting,
uh,
to the effect that this is,
this is proof that the system is rigged against black people so that,
that's more or less what I was politically as of maybe five years ago.
So yeah,
that was very much in my upbringing.
It was in the water,
uh,
in my,
in my social environment and intellectual environment growing up.
How much of that is part of the whole thing of just being around a certain set
of young people that believe a certain thing so that you all sorta believe it
together,
whether it's ultimately true or not.
Yeah,
I think,
I think we're social animals and,
and we're heavily incentivized psychologically to not break ranks with the norms
of our social group.
So if,
if,
if those norms are that you have to believe in the god Vishnu Shiva,
than most people are going to,
uh,
grow up believing those things.
And it takes a kind of a rare personality to,
to be a contrarian in that context.
And if the norms are you have to believe in,
in,
in systemic racism,
you have to believe that America is a unique evil,
then people will grow up believing those things.
And likewise,
if the norm is,
uh,
you know,
um,
abortion is murder and there is only one God and it's the Christian God and
homosexuality is a sin than most people in that context,
we'll,
we'll end up believing those things.
So,
yeah,
I mean my,
as far as my upbringing,
I think I can remember meeting precisely one Republican and he was my fifth
grade history teacher and he was such a good history teacher that,
you know,
in this public school that it kind of made up for the fact that he was a
republican because all the parents who want their kids to get ahead wanted them
in his class right now.
So you know,
there's something there there.
Yeah.
Yes,
yes.
But I guess,
yeah,
long story short,
it was very much of an echo,
very much an echo chamber.
Very ideologically siloed.
Yeah.
Okay.
So so far your story I think sounds pretty consistent with a lot of what's going
on with,
with young people.
How old are you now?
2122 okay.
So you said in 2013 so only about five years ago.
He's like,
you're 17
you're sort of in this thing,
this is the beginning of black lives matter.
When did you start realizing that perhaps it wasn't as much of a positive as it
had sort of been laid out to be?
Well,
I think it's,
it's hard to reconstruct one's own narrative after the fact,
but I remember one thing being significant,
which was when,
uh,
Michael Brown was killed in Ferguson.
I remember being in my first year of college taking,
taking a class at Julliard and we were talking about this killing and it was
just obvious from the point of view of most in the class,
including the professor,
that this was just another in a long line of examples of black men being
brutalized in a country that fundamentally does not want them to succeed,
to succeed.
And I don't know what like what it was.
It may have been because I had a roommate who was from,
from Arizona,
from a very different kind of political climate who was skeptical of this and I
didn't even know how one could be skeptical of this.
It was so jarring to meet a person.
I liked that or many people I liked that were skeptical of the things I took for
granted.
Yeah.
Were you guys able to get into it?
Because that's always one of the big problems here is that people can't do this
stuff with their friends anymore.
The thing is,
I think we were such good friends at that point for a political reasons that,
you know,
no amount of politics was gonna was gonna destroy that.
But I think I just spent one night reading the complete testimony from,
from uh,
from Michael Brown's friend and from the police officer.
And I came away thinking,
well,
if the police officer's telling the truth,
then that was a justified shooting.
If his friend is telling the truth,
then it was unjustified.
But the,
I don't know who's telling the truth and no one in my class knew either.
But everyone had the same opinion.
So that,
I mean I remember that being significant.
I remember,
remember speaking up about that,
like when was the moment that you were kind of going all right,
I got to say something about this?
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure that I spoke up about it.
I'm not sure I would've had the confidence to speak up about it.
Yeah.
Were there a couple of other things after that?
Cause I,
I find it to be one of these things that once you see this thing for what it is
that then it sort of happens very quickly.
I think a lot of people that watch this show,
I've acknowledged that because I think it's a lot of former former lefties or
whatever you want to call it,
that kind of see one moment like you just laid out and then they start looking
at other things and going,
wait a minute.
Maybe that's not how it is.
Maybe that person's not racist just because I disagree with them on this or
whatever the case.
I guess I can,
I can put it to two
quick moments.
One was,
uh,
once I,
once I arrived at Columbia,
I heard of this Guy John mcwhorter,
who I,
I,
I had no reason to believe anything about at the time,
but I just went,
I don't know,
a whim.
I went to the library and just search his name and pick the first book I could
find.
And it was called authentically black.
And it's a series of essays he wrote in the early two thousands about the fact
that it's viewed as authentically black to con constantly pointing the finger at
white people for any given problem in the black community.
Whether or not the evidence bears that out and uh,
because it's viewed as authentically black,
there's this incredible taboo on anyone who thinks differently.
And I was reading,
I was reading these essays and I remember thinking,
Oh my God,
this is,
this is right.
And I've never heard a black person say this out loud,
but it's,
it's obviously right.
And I didn't know you could say that.
I remember that that moment being significant,
but still the,
I mean,
these subjects are so hard to talk about.
I,
I do remember doing at some point doing MDM may and this is where most people
have their break.
Yes.
Um,
I guess this maybe makes the,
the,
the red pill analogy a little bit too literal.
There you go.
But I do remember,
I mean,
because you know,
I don't,
I don't enjoy being the black person at odds with most black people around me
are getting accused as I sometimes do of being self hating or an uncle Tom.
Like I don't enjoy that.
That's,
that's very much a cost of what I'm doing psychologically.
But I remembered,
remember doing Mtma and I was talking to a black friend of mine about race
issues and you know,
if you've ever done MTMA you know,
just puts you in this totally clear head space where you love everyone around
you so much and you love yourself.
And I remember we were talking about race issues and I was articulating more of
the kind of points of view that I articulate now.
And I,
it felt so silly that I had ever had a hang up talking about these things in any
other context.
And you know,
after that I just,
I felt like,
like there's no reason I can't try to approximate that more and more often.
Of course it's,
it's much harder when you're sober.
But the analogy though,
or the metaphor of the red build really has some value here.
How did that conversation end up?
I mean,
the MTMA laced conversation bubble.
I feel like base all,
all MTMA laced conversations go well.
Yeah.
I mean something has to be,
yeah,
it is.
I just,
yeah,
I think,
I think if we add more and more enter conversations with a mindset of the person
I'm talking to has reasons to believe what they believe and they're coming from
a good place,
then a lot of conversations can go well.
That said,
I've had a lot of conversations with people since then that have gone extremely
well.
Sorry.
Extremely poorly.
Yeah.
And um,
have ended quite bitterly.
Yeah.
And I want to get to some of that and some of the things that people call you
and all that,
so,
okay.
So you have these,
you know,
a couple of successive moments of,
of waking up.
Um,
when did you finally start talking about this stuff?
You know,
I think,
um,
I,
I talked about it here and there with friends and family,
but,
and I had been trying to write about it a bit for the school newspaper and just
writing on my own,
but not publishing over the past year.
But I think what,
what,
what did it was when Kanye tweeted,
uh,
I liked the way,
I love the way Candace own thinks when he tweeted that something about that
moment was so inspiring to me to see someone who nobody on earth would question
their quote blackness.
Because in many ways Kanye is viewed as,
as the picture of blackness.
However one cashes out that term,
um,
to just to see him break ranks,
to see him break,
break the taboo,
even though he did it in a way that,
you know,
even though he's not an intellectual,
he said crazy things about slavery that,
that aren't true and endorse someone who I don't,
I don't see myself as having very much in common with namely,
namely Candace.
It just,
the fact that he was willing to break the taboo at all,
someone of his platform was so inspiring to me that that's when I started
writing for Colette.
Yeah.
So what was,
was this the first piece you put out for court?
I think that was the very first,
very first piece.
Okay.
So the title of the piece,
as I said,
was high price of steel.
Yeah.
This one was different.
This one was,
um,
uh,
this one was about Kanye and Candice.
This was right.
Right.
So this one got more traction.
The one you're,
uh,
sorry.
Okay.
So I think this is,
so I don't think I was,
you were on my radar from that one,
although that probably that whole thing,
the whole kidney thing just sort of broke in such a crazy way though.
There were so many pieces written.
Um,
okay.
So let's back up then.
So then when you write this piece about Kanye,
Candace,
now,
you know,
Kansas is a friend of mine.
She's been on the show.
Uh,
I like her.
She has some tactics that are,
that are not my thing,
but that's her thing.
And I can disagree with people and all that.
Um,
your basic feeling though,
this was a net good no matter what.
Um,
are there risks though in,
uh,
you know,
taking somebody like a Kanye and having that be the moment that wakes up people
because you don't know where he's ever going to go with things or it's just the
action itself enough?
Yeah,
I guess time will tell.
I think it is inconvenient that Kanye,
I love his music and,
and I've been a fan for a long time,
but he clearly has some narcissistic elements to his personality.
Uh,
he,
he's clearly not someone who deeply the subjects that,
that he sometimes talks about.
So he kind of took a very blunt sledge hammer to a taboo,
which I appreciated.
But there are,
there are serious downsides to that.
Namely when he says that slavery was slavery was a choice,
something that ignorant seems to discredit his taking the sledge hammer to the
taboo when I do think they're separable in principal.
I also think
when he said,
you're talking about when he said that on TMZ,
right?
Yes.
And his counter argument to that was that he means that it's,
it was sort of a mindset I think was his counter.
Right?
Yeah.
Right.
So just that,
that sound byte reads so awfully because it seems so uninformed regardless of
what his,
his intent was there that it can,
it can seem to discredit that he did a good thing on the net on net balance.
And you know,
I also,
I,
you know,
I have,
I have reservations about cat cat as owners as well.
I've,
I've seen her a reason in ways that I think don't make much sense,
although I have some points of agreement with there too.
But like I said,
I think I,
I think there's a taboo that is incredibly strong right there.
There are lots of black people who agree with some version of,
of my takes on race and are absolutely mortified to say so because there's this
massive taboo.
Yeah.
And that's also why,
for again,
whatever my disagreements are with Candace,
it's like I see her as someone that's trying so desperately to break something,
the very thing that you're talking about.
So it's like if she's using tactics that maybe I wouldn't use or you know,
tweets in a in a more hostile way at people or whatever that I wouldn't do.
It's like I don't know that I am the one that should be telling you how to
behave in that regard.
Does that make sense to you?
Not so much.
Only because I feel like there are a lot of people who might like what Candace
says on race for example,
so someone can just says,
you know,
to go,
it goes to a college and says and sees all of all of these black students
reminding her of the history of Jim Crow,
which they didn't even experience and using that as as as a rhetorical weapon.
And Candace says,
listen,
you were born in 1990 right,
I completely agree with that.
That is,
that is a message that needs to be hammered home,
which is that histories in the past and we have to be getting past history.
But you know,
when she says that you're on the democratic plantation,
I think that is a kind of exaggeration that is not useful because people with a
different set of intellectual priors,
we'll just hear that and be immediately closed off to,
to whatever else she says.
And you know,
I've also heard her just reason in ways on,
on Joe Rogan for example,
when he pressed her on climate change,
kind of appealing to a sort of feeling over facts kind of way of thinking,
which is actually quite characteristic of,
of far left.
But you know,
she,
I think she also gets treated unfairly and she gets assumed to be a sellout.
Um,
which I think is,
is,
is ridiculous,
ridiculous assumption to make about people in general unless they make it
absolutely clear that they are.
So,
you know,
she's,
she's someone I would be happy to talk to at some point,
but
I'm happy to set that up if you'd like to make it happen.
Okay.
So you write this piece now,
this is the first public piece that you've written about this stuff.
Did you have any idea what kind of reaction you were in store for?
No,
no.
Walk me through that moment.
Um,
yeah,
I think it got retweeted by Christina Hoff Summers and Jordan Peterson and Sam
Harris and,
and some other people and it really,
really blew up.
And uh,
yeah,
I that was psychologically distressing because,
you know,
I'm a normal person,
so when I go from having 50 Twitter followers to 10,000 in a week or something
like that,
that is a pretty life deranging moment.
And uh,
it was,
it was just kind of physical stress,
a low level physical stress all day and not sleeping as much,
but you,
you get,
I think you get,
you'd be surprised what you can get used to.
Um,
so
we were you shocked were you were getting defense from and where you were
getting outrage from or I assume you expected it at least at some level.
Yeah.
No,
I don't think I was shocked by that.
I mean,
I knew at this point I knew at this point exactly who would be very pissed off
by,
by my,
my opinions.
And at this point I had resigned myself to,
to be to those people being pissed off at me.
And No,
I'm not,
I mean,
I'm not surprised that they're quote IDW types,
uh,
liked my work because I like a lot of their work.
Um,
so no,
I guess that wasn't,
that wasn't so surprising.
Yeah.
So when you then wrote the piece,
the high price of state,
the high price of steel grievances,
uh,
which was also in quilt that you started with a quote from felonious monk that I
thought was,
was sort of worth diving into here.
They tried to get me to hate white people,
but someone would always come along and spoil it.
There's something about that quote that strikes me as so relevant to what's
going on right now that we are not looking at people as individuals and that
every time you do,
you will be pleasantly surprised because most people are not walking around in
this state of hate.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I think it's striking.
I mean,
I,
and I,
um,
juxtapose that quote with another from the New York Times,
from a New York Times op Ed published last year,
uh,
which argued that black children should be taught to fear white children based
on the history of racism in this country.
Uh,
and the quote was,
as against our Gazi national hopes,
I will teach my boys,
my black boys to have profound doubts that friendship with white people as
possible.
Right?
So that got published in The New York Times in 2017.
Uh,
you know,
Sarah Jon got hired,
uh,
having,
having written incredibly nasty tweets about white people in 2018 by the New
York Times,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's disturbing to me that you can't,
you can't really find at this point on the left,
even on the mainstream left,
just the simple articulation that a person's race does not matter to their moral
worthiness to their intellectual worthiness.
It is,
it is an irrelevant character.
You can't find the language of,
of,
of appeals to colorblind humanity virtually anywhere on the left at this point.
Um,
that,
that is disturbing to me.
How shocking is it to you?
Because I think people are still kind of shocked,
you know,
I've been banging this drum for quite some time and I think I see people waking
up to it now and I'm like,
man,
how didn't you see this?
You know,
these,
these last couple of years because it's so obvious to me that we've gotten here.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
it,
it is shy.
Me.
I do remember growing up,
you know,
in the,
in the public school system,
in my town we would have Martin Luther King Day assemblies is very diverse town,
maybe 25 30% black and 60% white.
And we would,
we would get the,
you know,
the,
I have a dream's style ethic around what it means to be a human and how
important or unimportant one skin color is.
And it seemed like such a,
it seems like there's such a good argument to me and it is the best argument
with regard to people's,
you know,
the,
the assumed,
I guess
w w w what I mean to say here is that I've been in spaces at Columbia for
example,
or conversations where my being black,
it was obvious to me that there was an assumption of,
of moral worthiness or have a kind of heightened moral knowledge than I would
have as a black person that a white person wouldn't have.
And you know,
I think,
I think I,
I'm not the first to make this analogy of course,
but the real religious analogy and the analogy to original sin is pretty apt.
Um,
because it,
I mean the,
the way though,
this has a lot to do with black history also because the way I,
the way I see it,
they're kind of two ways to study history.
There's the conventional way,
which is,
you know,
you study World War One,
you study the causes and consequences read different takes on,
on,
on the significance.
And once you've studied,
all you need to know,
you move on to the next topic.
But then there's a religious way of studying history,
which is,
it's not enough to know the facts.
We have to go somewhere on Sunday,
every,
you know,
every single week and learn,
talk about same stories over and over again.
So this is,
you know,
it's,
it's the difference between how an atheist learns about the life of Jesus and
how a Christian learns about the life of Jesus Jesus and relearn it every week
for the rest of their life.
In my view,
how we're looking at the history of race relations in this country,
the history of racism,
we are more and more putting it in the religious category of history of where,
you know,
I can read a piece about the history of lynching in the New York Times almost,
once every two or three months.
Right.
Let me,
lynching is a decades old crime at this point.
And Avi,
I mean,
Jesus,
Great.
Obviously it was a,
a heinous staying on,
on this country's legacy,
you know?
But then the number of deaths that that is is the highest amount quoted in New
York Times with regard to how many black people were lynched in this country is
around 4,000.
Right.
Every single year.
Twice that many black people die of homicide.
And I,
you just don't even hear about that in the New York Times.
So what do you make of the fact then?
So this is something that like a Sean Hannity,
he'll talk about he'll,
he'll say that exactly.
Yeah.
And now if you say,
and then people will say that somehow that makes him racist cause he's been
focusing on black on black crime or something like that.
So how do we have that conversation then?
Because I think partly what's happening is the outreach,
you know,
someone mentions it,
he happens to be someone obviously on the right.
Uh,
I don't know what his intentions are.
I don't know the guy,
but he's,
he's at least talking about it.
What you just said,
people aren't talking about it.
Yes.
But then pays a heavy price to talk about it.
That then has the chill effect that it's like people are like,
all right,
I'm not going to talk about it.
So we can look at the crime statistics in Chicago every week and you should care
about these statistics where there's people who are white or black or whatever,
but people are just like,
I don't want to touch it because,
yeah,
I don't want these labels.
Yeah,
it is.
It is decidedly.
I mean,
this is one of the reasons why,
you know,
I'm,
I don't see myself as a natural ally to a Candace Owens for example,
because there are so many other things that she says that,
uh,
you know,
that,
that I don't agree with.
And I guess it's the Sean Hannity problem too,
because if you can't criticize a Sean Hannity or Candice Owens for all of the
things that they're saying that are know on unjustified by the evidence,
you know,
it's cat is Kate Candice's case.
It might be climate change or,
or whatever it is,
um,
for Sean Hannity could be other things.
Uh,
then I guess you just have to be able to,
to make these subtle distinctions.
But at the end of the day,
homicide is the leading cause of death for young black men aged 15 to 34
according to the CDC.
It is not the leading cause of homicide for any other race or,
or age group.
Um,
can we talk about that?
That,
I mean the,
is it the case that we're,
we're,
we're so close to white people turning the hoses on us again
to the Sean Hannity and,
and they're supposedly deplorable,
um,
you know,
followers that that were just so the threat of white supremacy is so ever
present of resurgent white supremacy that we can't talk about the leading cause
of death among young black men,
that,
that is not sustainable.
Amy,
the fundamental problem I see with how the left in general thinks about race is
that the concerns about race and racism are totally unattached to the degree to
which black people are suffering on any given issue.
Right?
So we're talking about the leading cause of death for young black men.
And I never read about this in the New York Times and I,
and I know that I won't.
Right?
So this is,
this is a problem that is central.
It is.
It is bigger than the problem of police violence.
It is bigger than you know than the problem of microaggressions that is bigger
than the problems of of systemic bias and yet there is,
there's virtually no concern for this on the left because the way I see many
progressives think about race issues is a perpetrator side concern,
which is if the perpetrators of the problem are white that it's worth talking
about.
If the perpetrators of the problem happened to be black and it's not,
we're talking about,
the problem with that is that it's untethered to any concern for the level of
suffering on this side.
On the victim side.
Do you think it's a fair estimation to see this is the new racism in a weird way
like it's almost uncomfortable to say it,
but I had a an educator in the UK here in the summer,
Katherine verbal sing and that's basically what she said that these people are
now the racists,
that the racist ideas of the day are actually coming out of the left.
Now.
I don't want to use the same tactics.
Right.
I don't want to sit here and be like,
they're all racist and blah,
blah,
because we know that that doesn't really get us anywhere.
Yeah.
The general idea of that,
do you think that that's a fair way to frame things?
I,
I wouldn't frame it.
I mean the way I would frame it is that there is a kind of racism on the left
and it's the kind of racism where the New York Times higher,
higher is a writer who says that,
who celebrates the idea that white people stop breathing.
Right.
And doesn't apologize for it.
Yeah.
No concern with how that,
how that's going to translate to,
you know,
white people in this country who have vastly less privileged than,
the tech writer at the New York Times.
And what about that statement that they issued defending her?
Yeah,
you saw that where it said something about the hate she gets as a young Asian
woman and it's like
what?
That that's now a new thing that you get to be racist because you've gotten
trolled online.
Well.
Yeah,
I mean that,
so coming back to the question that is that that is,
I'm happy to call that a kind of racism for sure.
It's the only reason I would say there I wouldn't go as far as to say they are
the new racist is because there are still racist on the other side and I fully
expect there to always be some amount of racist in society and some amount of
racist incidents like the way this is another problem with the way many on the
left think about race is that they,
they tend to view the problem of racism.
Kind of like we view the problem with smallpox,
which is to say something that can be fully eradicated down to the very last
person who has it.
And then we can put a date on the time when smallpox is no longer a problem
forever.
Whereas I,
and I would argue anyone who's really thinking rationally about this problem
should view racism as more,
more like a problem like murder,
right?
Like the murder rate in New York City used to be 10 times higher than it was
today.
Just 20 years ago it was,
it was absolute carnage.
So that the,
the rate is,
it's come down tenfold.
New York is notoriously safe at this point is something like 200 murders,
two or 300 murders last year.
Right.
What would it take to get the murder rate down to zero to the point where there
was not a single murder in New York City,
you'd probably murder everybody.
Yes,
you have to get me.
Do you have to embrace a totally totalitarian vibe from the top down?
It could be done,
but it would not be worth what it took to get there.
You'd hit diminishing returns.
So I view the problem of reducing racism,
reducing racist incidents against black people as a problem,
like homicide rather than smallpox,
which is to say you can certainly reduce it and we have massively,
but there was a point at which in a country of 350 million,
there will always be enough people who are racist to,
to justify a certain amount of racist incidents and to fight it beyond that
endlessly you hit diminishing returns.
Yeah.
And also that it's depressing and it kind of sucks,
but people can be racist.
Like privately,
you can be racist,
know you can't discriminate against people and there's all sorts of reasons that
you can't bring that into public life,
but in your own mind,
in your own home,
you can be,
I would prefer people not be,
but that they're trying to eradicate like something that's actually just part of
the mind.
Yeah.
You want to,
you want to educate people enough so that they hopefully won't hold those views,
but that is the diminishing returns because you're literally going to be in
people's houses at that,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a question of not.
Yeah.
I mean,
I guess there's a question of what your view of human nature is.
This comes down to very fundamental pillars of one's a political ideology,
which is do you have a kind of Utopian view of human nature where there's
nothing tragic about us,
nothing flawed about us,
and all of the flaws come from bad ideas and the culture and humans are
naturally poised to be just perfectly selfless until we get ruined by society.
I see that,
that,
I think there's no reason to believe that at this point,
right?
Like chimpanzees and murder and like there were animals in the animal kingdom.
It's not to say that where our human nature is fundamentally evil either it's,
it's clearly there's a,
there's a wide range of potential there,
but there's no,
no reason to assume that we're evolved to be not racists or that were evolved to
be,
um,
you know,
woke perfectly woke or that it's possible to get to a point where everyone in
society has been fully purged of every ounce of evil in their heart.
I mean,
that is such a utopian outlook.
And like I said,
the,
to the extent that you're fixated on that goal,
to the exclusion of the costs of your fixation,
once you hit diminishing returns,
you will be finding a fight that is a net bad for society.